Sean Hannity on his radio show was
confronted by a caller saying dude you
lied on air you knew Trump didn't really
win in 2020 we know from the text
messages that were revealed and we know
from Rupert Murdoch's deposition under
oath we know you were lying when you
went on air and said oh there was fraud
and Trump really won and all of this
different stuff
and Hannity
tries to backpedal and explain away and
it is a delight to see this uh is from
the Ari melber MSNBC show where they
compiled a bunch of different things the
back story of course is that on air on
Fox after the 2020 election Hannity and
Laura Ingram and Tucker and many others
were uh pretending we now know that they
agreed yeah Trump really won it was
stolen Joe Biden didn't really win and
privately they were texting each other
saying these people are crazy this
doesn't make any sense take a look at
this you knew the election wasn't stolen
from Trump and you guys lied about it
anyway because you felt you had a good
reason so this is a caller to Hannity's
show a few days ago no if you listen to
what I said on the air every day what
did I talk about let me remind you many
Americans do not believe that this
election was fair I feel that way wow
it's a corrupt and an embarrassing
disgrace what I'm asking you if you own
knew that the election wasn't stolen
from Trump and yet no no no you're not
listening to what I'm saying I said I
had problems that there were Integrity
issues our Dominion systems prone to
human error 72 million Americans voted
for Donald Trump all of them all of us
deserve an answer
right so this is just a sampling of the
placating that Hannity did
so listen
um it's at this point there really isn't
a question we know that people like
Hannity and Ingram and Tucker Carlson
are entertainers and they are
propagandists and at the time the way
the wind was blowing they couldn't come
out and say guys
Trump lost that's it that's what they
knew that's what they believed that's
what they said privately Trump lost Joe
Biden one
they're not in a position to actually
say that to Their audience because there
were 63 lawsuits and they were their
producers were booking guests for them
like Sydney Powell and Rudy Giuliani and
the entire thing so they did what they
had to do as entertainers while
privately there had they had their views
about the facts of the matter this
proves to us they aren't true believers
when it comes to someone like Sydney
Powell that kooky lawyer who has been
disbarred now from multiple bar
associations
she does seem like a True Believer she
actually seems insane she raises
religious aspects to what she did and
believes and all these she seems
genuinely out of her mind like a True
Believer but Hannity Tucker Ingram and
others they didn't believe it we
suspected they didn't believe it they
wanted to maintain their audiences they
wanted to maintain their jobs and their
incomes and probably in many of these
cases they wanted to maintain
friendliness with Donald Trump himself
good for this caller for confronting
Hannity we will see what the
repercussions are but I'm increasingly
reading legal analyzes that suggest Fox
News could really really really be in
trouble here this is not you know it yes
Rupert Murdoch has the money to pay the
defamation lawsuit
but that this could
significantly hurt Fox News depending on
what happens and that would be great and
it's not about me saying you know I know
that they're I'm already getting
messages from right winger saying David
you're just advocating for censorship
when you say I hope this lawsuit is
terrible for Fox News you're advocating
for them to be censored no no no
we are talking here about consequences
to defamation consequences to defamation
we're talking about a legal system and a
legal structure here I am a defender of
Fox News being allowed to say whatever
they want to say but there are certain
things they can say which could have
consequences if some of their speech is
defamatory there is a legal process that
is part of our judicial system that
would hold them accountable so what I am
talking about what I am pushing for is
accountability it is not about revenge
censorship or curtailing Free Speech Fox
News did this thing they have been sued
and it is now in the courts to figure
out what the repercussions should be
maybe tomorrow maybe Wednesday I will do
a deeper dive into how this might
actually destroy Fox News